.
♪ ♪WL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
>> Sea WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
AND TIGHT BIDEN'S PSIDENCY
FULL OUT IMPLODING,UT
APPARENTLY NO ONEOLD
JOE BIN.
ACRDING TO REPORTS,HE
PRESIDT HAS DECIDED TO RU FOR
REELECON IN 202 BRAGGING TO
RACKBAMA THAT HE I THE ONLY
DECRATHO COULD ACTUAY WIN.
IS BRINGS US TO AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE, HAS JOE BEN REALLY LOST
TOUCH WITHLL REALITY?
IT'S A SERIOUS QUESTION,
UNFOUNATELY,VERY WEEK WELL
WATCH COMEBSER HIS COGNITIVE
ABILITY GETSORSENDORSE,
NEW ISSUES AND INSIGOLL
UND O FIFTH OF AMERINS
N'T EN THINK J BID WILL
MAKE IT THROUGH H FIRSTERM, ONL
VERY LIKELY HE WILLAKE IT ALLFO,
AT A TINY EVENT I
NEW MPSHE, WELL, JOE WAS IN
RARE FM, AS USUAL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MAINE, N HAMPSHIRE,MERICA
ON THEEND -- NOT ONHE MEND
Y LONGER, THE ARE ON THE
MOVE, AND WERE COMING AT R
CHALLENGESROM A POSITION OF
STRENGTH
>>ean:E ARE GOINGO HIRE
A FULL-TIME IERPRER JUST TO
MAKEUREE GET IT RIT.
UNRTUNATELY, IT GETS EN
RSE.
ASKED HIM A QSTION ABOUTWHO
AMERICA'S EUROPN AIES A
THE R IN UKRAINE.
TAKE A LOO
CAN YOU DISCUSSITH THE
ALLIESODAY AUT UKRAINE?
>> NEW HAMHIRE
>>EALLY
>>'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT
NEW HAMPSHE.
>> INDERAND>> Sean:ERE NOT GOI O
THINK ABOUT LTEEK ONHIS
PROGRAM, DONALD TRUMPAS O
THIS PROGRAM F 40 MINUTES, T
BETTER PT OF 40 MITES FM
AFUENT, ENERGETIC INFORMED,
IDEA I MEAN, COULD JOE BRYANT
ER DOHAT?APPARENTLY HEEEDS TOLAR
ECOMIC WOES ANDVERYTHINGELSE ONA
LOOK.
>> IT'S BEBSOLUTELY CLEA
ABOUT W WE HAV SUCH HIG
PRICES NOW, TWO REASO.
FIRST WAS VID.
AND THE COND BIG REASO FOR
INFLATN IS VLADIMIR PUTI
NOA JOKE.
>>ean:OT A JOKE.
NOT A JOKE.
IT'S PUTIN.
ITS COVIDHE LKS TIRED, DOESN'T H
ANAY, BIDEN ONCEGAIN MAKING
EXCUSES FOR S OWN ECONOC
CISIONS AND FAILUSOME HIS
OW ENERGY DECISIONS A
ILURES, INJECTED TRILLIO OFDOLLY
T ECONOMY.
HE RESTRICTED ALL T OIL ANDGAS A
OVER THE COUNT, WE SHOD YOU
THESE CHARTS LAST WEEK, W WL
SHOW YOU AGAIN TONIGHT WE
ALREADY HAD 40 YR HH OF
INVADED UKRAINE GET G PRICESWERN
BEFORE RSIA INVADED UKRNE.
JOE IS JUST LYING, JUST LI HE
LIED THAT HE NEVER HAD A SGLE
DISTRACTION WI ZER EXPERIENCE
HUER ABOUT HIS FEIGN
BUSISS DEALINGS
BUT THEIG GUYEOWNOW HAD MANDISCD
MEETGS.
NOW JOE REFUSES TO ACCEPTRESPONC
ANHING
ITS ALWAYS SOMEO ELSE'S
FAULT,HE BUCK DS NO STOP
CONTROL.ND IT IALL T OF
ANYWAYTHEUCKEYE GAS STO
WITH U
IT SEEMSIKE IT NEVER WILL
TAKE, HE WILL NER TE
RESPON BODY FORNYTHG BUTTHE REAA
PRESIDENT  THE UNITED STATES
IN AN OBVIOUS SEP COGNITIVE
DECLINE AN A FORMER LAW SCHOOL
CHIEAND PLAGIARIZE HER ALWAYS
LACKED INTEGRI, KIND OF LIKE
THE BIDENAY, LIKE FATHER, LI
SON.
WE ARE NOWEARING ACCORDING TO
MY SOURCES TIGHT BIG NEWSSURROUS
CRIMAL INVTIGAON, ITS
FORTHCOMING.THISDMINTRATION IS A
DISAER ON SO MANY FROS AFRANKLYP
TRACK.
IF TT HAPPENS TO HUNTER, LET
ME TELL YOU SOMEING, TSEEMAILS ,
E, AND IF YOU JUST SWITCHHE
LAST NAME JUST BEFE, YOU KNO
THMEDI MOBOULD HAVE VERY
DIFFERENTEACTION.
W WITHIDEN PUL NUMBERS
ATERING TO HTORI LOW'S, NBC
NEWOWS, CBS NEW LOW FOX NEWS
NEWOW,3% NEW LOW WH
INNIAC, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
BIG N KN MY PLANS TO
TURN THINGAROUND, THEY WT
JOE BIN TO FOCUS O DOMESTIC
ISSUES.
WILL HFINAYAD DOWN TO E
SOUTHEORDE, CUT TAX TO
EASEHE BDENF INFTION?
LL HE UNLSH DESTICPRODUCTION OF?
SPOILE ALE: HE'S NOT GOING TO
DO ANY O TSE TNGS.
INSTD, JOE WILL LIKELY AVEL
TO A FEW CITIESLOSE TO THE
WHITE HOUSE,NCOURAGE AMECANS
SO-CALLED EQUI PROAMS.NDE
WLUSH MORE SOCIIST
SPENNG PROPOSAHICH WOULD
MA INFTION EVEN WOR, AND
GET THIS, BID'S N ECONOMICREPORR
GEND -- AGAIN, GENDER, 1
TIMES.
INATION IS ONLY MENTIONED 87
TIME
EXAINE TT TO YOURIDS.
ANYW,ATURALLY, JOEILL ALSO
VILIFY HIS PITICAL OPPONTS,
SMEA THEM ASACIST AND SIST
AN OF COURSE, HE WL CONTINUE
TO BLAME ALL OFIS FAIRES ON
COVI19 AND VDIMIR PUTIN,
ICH IS A PRETTY WRD STRATEGY
SINCBIDEN ONCE VOWED TOTAND
UP T VDIMIR AND PROMISETO
UT DN THE VIRUS.
NEITR OF THOSE THIS HEHAPPENEDND
BIDE NOTNLY FAID TO SHUT
ADMINISTRATIONAN'T EVEN GET
THEIR MESSAGING STRAIGHT ONWHETA
PEOPLE SHOULD BE WEING MASK
ON A PLANE O A TRAIN.
YEERDAY, A FEDAL JUDGE IN
ORID STRUCK DOW BIDEN'S MASMANDW
IF T ADMINISTRATIO WILL
APAL THE RULING.
AT O POINT TOD, BIDEN SAID
TH WEARING A MAS WAS A
INDIVIDUAL CICE, THEN A FHOURS D
EVERYONE CONTINUE TO WEAR THEIR
SKS.
CLEARLY, LEADERSP IS NOT
EXACY SOMETNG THE
ADMISTRATION DOES WL.THAT IS BET
A LEADER.HE IS CORRUPT,OGNIVELY
STRUGGLINGA CAREER POLITICIAN
WHO IS FEW DECADES PT HIS
PRIMI HAVE NO IDEA I HE WILLACTB